a buffalo would make a worthy adversary
and the young males rise to the
challenge
but a buffalo bull weighs over four
times more than just one of them they
can't do it alone
to hunt Buffalo the family will need the
strength of a pride male white head and
dewclaw also join the hunt
the buffalo herd bunches together it's
their best defense the Lions will battle
to single out an individual
panicked by the Lions the herd bolts the
Lions give chase but it's Duke Law who
outlasts them all
as with the hippo
they must knock the Buffalo off balance
but this time the females have helped
attacking the Buffalo from every
direction the pride works together to
topple its quarry
in the end the young males bring the
Buffalo to its knees
it's a defining moment the juveniles are
finally part of the team the entire
pride will feed tonight
there's no squabbling for space the
buffalo accommodates them all